well we start this hour with that
breaking news uh the arrest made uh on
suspicion of murder a man in his 30s
this is regarding the murder of ashling
murphy the school teacher who was
murdered last week in county offaly we
can speak to our correspondent david
blevins now and david this arrest took
place shortly after ashling's funeral
today
yes police are providing very little
detail at this stage for operational
reasons other than to confirm that
detectives investigating the murder of
the 23 year old primary school teacher
last wednesday have arrested a man in
his 30s he's currently being detained at
telemore guard a station under section
four of the criminal justice act 1984
and that questioning could go on for
some time the anger this year kona the
irish police service are adamant that
they will not be making any further
comment at this stage but it is
nonetheless a significant development
and as you say it comes just a matter of
hours after the small village of mount
bolas and county awfully came to a
complete standstill for the funeral of
ashley murphy there can be no question
whatsoever about the esteem in which she
was held literally hundreds upon
hundreds of people turned out and packed
into and around the small parish of
saint bridget
the mourners were led by her parents her
brother her sister and her boyfriend
ireland's president michael d higgins
and his wife sabina came along there
were some very touching scenes as they
comforted the family in the church and
gently placed their hands on ashleen's
coffin also there the prime minister
antishock mehal martin and that's
because really the murder of this young
woman has had an enormous impact both at
home and abroad people are not just
saddened by it they are very angry about
the fact that after all this time women
are still being subjected to violence
and there have been all sorts of vigils
and calls for a change in attitude for
this to be the watershed moment ashley
murphy was just one of those very
special people it seems
a very popular school teacher her own
class of five and six-year-olds provided
a guard of honor as her coffin arrived
at the church this morning she was a
talented camogie player on the pitch
very popular too and in fitting form i
think in this rural part of ireland
county awfully traditional musicians
both inside and outside the church paid
their respects to a very talented fiddle
player and i think that's the important
thing to remember today while the murder
investigation continues behind the
scenes and while there has been this
arrest this is a day when ashleen's
family and friends want to remember a
very beautiful young woman who was so
cruelly snatched away in unthinkable
circumstances